The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We started to talk
about the discrete time
Fourier transform last time.
This is probably something
you've been exposed to before,
and as in many cases, we're
looking at it in a very
different way than what you
probably looked at it before.
The discrete time Fourier
transform is simply the time
frequency dual of the
Fourier series.
Nothing more than that.
For any L2 function --
now we're talking about a
function of frequency, but a
function is a function.
So this is a complex valued
function of frequency.
If it's limited, if it's
truncated to the band from
minus w to plus w, then, in
fact, it's inverse Fourier
transform is given by this limit
in the mean of the sum
of the coefficients times
v sub k of f.
This is exactly the same as
the Fourier transform
replacing times with
frequencies, replacing w for t
over 2, and in the complex
frequency you're replacing a
to the plus 2 pi i here with e
to the minus 2 pi i in the
Fourier series.
So those are the only
differences, it's just
notational differences, and
aside from that, it works
exactly the same way.
The coefficients are
given by this.
We showed, when we were talking
about the Fourier
series, that these coefficients
exist as complex
numbers, they're
always finite.
You can calculate them
if you want to.
This quantity here can
be rather fishy.
This is this limit in the mean
which says that you have to
calculate this by looking at
the sum here over a finite
sum, over a finite sum this
is well-defined and
behaves very nicely.
As you go to the limit funny
things can happen, but the
thing that we showed is in terms
of energy, nothing funny
can happen.
I'm going to give you an example
of this kind of funny
business as we talk about the
sampling theorem in just a
couple of minutes.
So the u hat of f has
to be L1 since it is
limited in this way.
It has a continuous inverse
transform, which is this.
OK, so you can go from --
blah blah blah blah blah.
The discrete Fourier transform
is simply a transform between
a function and a sequence
of terms.
Now this bit here is something
we haven't
talked about before.
Because now we've talked about
Fourier transforms also, and
if you have an L2 function, u
hat of f, that L2 function has
a Fourier transform and an
inverse Fourier transform in
this case, which is u of t,
which is given by this
expression here, the
usual expression
for the Fourier transform.
Now, the thing that's peculiar
about this Fourier transform
is that since u hat of f is
limited, is truncated, this
transform here exists
everywhere.
We don't need a limit
in the mean here.
You can calculate this for
every t this exists.
This is a point-wise
convergent thing.
This is the thing that you're
used to when you think of
functions, because the function
is defined everywhere
in this case.
And since we're going to go into
the sampling theorem, it
had damned well better be
defined everywhere because
otherwise the sampling
theorem wouldn't make
any sense at all.
So, the inverse Fourier
transform of the discrete time
Fourier transform, as we
said, is this, it's a
limit in the mean.
Namely, you take more
and more terms here.
You get closer and closer to
this in terms of energy.
It doesn't say anything about
what happens for particular
values of f.
This is a sampling expansion
with t equals 1 over 2w.
OK, let's go back here.
We're talking about some
function of frequency which
has a Fourier series, it also
has a Fourier transform.
What we're interested in now
is what is the relationship
between these coefficients
here and a discrete time
Fourier transform and
this function here.
What I want to show you is
that, in fact, these two
things are very closely
related.
You can now go back to the
Fourier series itself and
relate the Fourier series
coefficients to the Fourier
transform and you'll get the
same kind of sampling
representation that we're
getting right now.
So, if we -- there's something
missing in what I'm
trying to say here.
Oh, I see what I'm trying
to do, sorry.
What I'm trying to do is to
take the inverse Fourier
transform of u hat of
f, which is given by
this expression here.
Temporarily I'm going to forget
about the fact that
this is a limit in the mean,
throw mathematics to the
winds, and simply take this
inverse transform.
Take the inverse transform
of this also.
So, when I take the inverse
transform of the sum, what I'm
going to get is the sum over k
of u sub k, and then in place
of this frequency function --
these are orthogonal functions
here, the things I listed
on the previous page --
I got u of t is the sum of
u sub k times these time
functions now.
These time functions are just
the Fourier transforms of
these frequency functions
here.
This is a set of orthogonal
wave forms here, which are
truncated sinusoids.
I want to take the Fourier
transform of these and the
Fourier transforms of these --
I should have put them both on
the same slide so you could
see what they are --
but in fact, in your homework
you're going to take the
inverse Fourier transform of
that and show that it is, in
fact, this.
That's just a nice exercise in
taking rectangular functions
and sinc functions and applying
shifts in both time
and frequency.
When you do this, this turns
out to have the inverse
transform of this.
So this is u of t is just this,
where this comes from
here, and then this turns out to
be the inverse transform of
this function here, which,
in fact, is just this.
Sorry for all of that.
So now if we want to try to
understand what this means,
suppose that you take a function
u of t, which is, in
fact, the inverse transform of
this u hat of f, which is
truncated to a finite
band limit.
If we then take v of t equal to
u of t everywhere except on
the sample points, and on every
sample point we simply
add 1 to v -- in other words,
v of kt is equal to
u of kT plus 1.
So we take this nice smooth
function that we have here,
and at every sample point
we simply add 1.
So now the question is, is this
new function I have still
baseband limited or isn't it?
You see you can't answer that
question because we weren't
careful enough to say
what we meant by a
baseband limited function.
Usually when you talk about a
baseband limited function,
you're talking about a function
whose Fourier
transform is zero, except in the
range minus w to plus w.
Well, this new function v of t
here has the property that its
Fourier transform is zero
outside of minus w to plus w.
And therefore if you define
baseband limited as functions
whose Fourier transform is zero
outside of limits, then
the sampling theorem
doesn't hold.
So what do we do about this?
Well, the easiest thing to do
about it is to change what we
mean by baseband limited to what
you would have meant if
we hadn't going through all
of this mathematics.
In other words, the Fourier
transform cuts both ways -- u
of t has a Fourier transform, u
hat of f, u hat of f has an
inverse transform, u of t.
What we mean now by baseband
limited is that u of t is the
inverse transform of a frequency
function, which is
limited to minus
w over plus w.
In other words, we will regard
u of t here as being baseband
limited, we will not
regard v of t as
being baseband limited.
Because we have these two
functions, u of t and v of t,
which both have the same Fourier
transforms, but which
are not equal to each other.
We want to, at this point, say
that the only one which is
really baseband limited is the
function which is the inverse
transform of u of t.
If you read the sampling theorem
as it's written in the
notes, that's exactly
what it says.
It defines this function u of
t to which the sampling
theorem applies in that way.
Well anyway, this
is the sampling
theorem at this point.
It says you can take
u of t, you can
express it in this way.
If I go back to the previous
slide, what we did here by
comparing u of t with this
expression for u sub k. u sub
k are the coefficients in the
discrete time Fourier
transform. u of t is this
inverse transform.
These quantities here
are almost the same.
This quantity here is just
evaluating this at particular
frequencies.
Namely, if for frequency f I
substitute in, if we're time
t, I substitute in k over 2w,
then this formula just becomes
that formula.
In other words, 2w times
u sub k is equal to u
evaluated at k over 2w.
You already saw that when you
looked at the Fourier series.
When you looked at the Fourier
series, you saw these
coefficients, which, in fact,
look like the Fourier
transform terms.
And which, in fact, were the
same as the Fourier transform
except for a scale factor at
some particular frequency.
Here we have these coefficients,
which are, in
fact, scaled versions of the
inverse transform of
particular times.
So the conclusion from that
is that, in fact, what the
discrete time Fourier transform
is is it's simply
the Fourier transform of the
sampling theorem expansion.
The two of them are duals in a
very different way than the
Fourier series and the
dtft are duals.
The dtft and the Fourier series
are duals in the sense
that if you take the expressions
for the Fourier
series and change frequency
for time and time for
frequency, you get
to the dtft.
Here what we're doing is taking
the dtft and simply
taking the inverse Fourier
transform of it, so that the
sampling theorem is, in
fact, the Fourier
transform of the dtft.
It's not the dual, it's the
Fourier transform itself.
Well, the discrete time Fourier
transform generalizes
to arbitrary frequency intervals
just as well as to a
baseband interval.
Namely, you can do exactly the
same thing as what we've just
done if you're looking not at
the frequency at the range of
frequencies from minus w to plus
w, but you shift that up
to any old place you want to and
look at delta minus w to
delta plus w.
And the fact the discrete time
Fourier transform, if you
don't put the rectangular
function in it is going to be
periodic anyway.
It's exactly the same
thing that we had
with a Fourier series.
With a Fourier series, we could
find the Fourier series
for a function limited between
minus t over 2
to plus t over 2.
Now by duality, we can find
the dtft for a function
limited between minus w plus
delta and plus w plus delta.
That's what we're doing here.
So the dtft in generalized form
is now this, and v sub k
is now the integral from delta
minus w to delta plus w of the
same old thing as before.
This is equal to this, which
is the same old thing as
before, except we now have this
shifted frequency in the
rectangular function.
So if we take the inverse
Fourier transform of this,
again, using the same duality
we had before, we get v of t
is equal to the sum times
the sinc function.
And the only difference now
that we're expanding this
given frequency band not
centered around zero but
centered around something else,
the only difference in
the sampling theorem is now
we have this rotating term
gyrating around up at this
frequency, k over 2w.
That's the only way in which
this is different from the
sampling theorem that
we had before.
I wish I could put more things
on one slide but you wouldn't
see them if I could.
So here's a Fourier transform
of the sum 1 over t, u of kt
time the sinc function.
Here it's the same thing.
That's one reason for comparing
these things sometimes.
1 over t in here.
OK, times, so it's the same
thing with this rotating term
which is the only difference.
Now, how many of you can see
that the Fourier transform of
this quantity is equal to
this sinc function?
I can't do that.
It's one of the things you're
going to do in your homework.
I get confused every time I do
it, and I got confused enough
to leave out the 1 over t
this time when I did it.
You just have to be patient
with that and do it a few
times and you'll find
that it's not --
well, it becomes automatic
after awhile.
It's one place where you
need plug and chug.
So now that we've generalized
the dtft to look at any old
frequency band instead of just
the frequency band around
zero, we can do the
same thing that we
did with time functions.
Namely, with a time function --
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You don't think
it should be a 1 over t?
Well, you very well might be
right because I didn't think
it should have been either
when I wrote it down.
But I don't see --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It was the--.
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's the
difference, yes, of course.
It's not the coefficient
that I have here,
it's the actual --
yeah.
Yes.
So it should be the
same as the--
Oh, I see the problem.
I shouldn't have had the 1
over t here, should I?
No.
I know one of them couldn't
be right.
It is right in the notes, so
you can sort it out there.
So, the thing we did when we
were dealing with a Fourier
series is we took an arbitrary
function of time, we segmented
it into time intervals and then
we expanded each one of
those time intervals into
a Fourier series.
By doing that we could take an
arbitrary L2 function and
represent it as an orthogonal
expansion over this double sum
of time shifts and
frequency terms.
We call that the truncated
sinusoidal expansion, the t
spaced truncated sinusoids and
we made an expansion out of
that that would allow us to
express any old L2 function in
terms of that.
Here we're going to
do the same thing.
We can take an arbitrary
frequency function, separate
into bands of frequencies.
You often want to do this in
digital communication when
you're looking at transmitting
information in different
bands, which you do all
the time in radio.
Somebody has a certain part of
the spectrum, they transmit a
signal there, somebody else
has another part of the
spectrum, they transmit
a signal there.
You can look at those different
signals which are in
different frequency bands,
they're all orthogonal to each
other, they don't interfere
with each other at all.
We're doing the same
thing here.
We're just saying an arbitrary
function can be split into
different frequency bands, each
one of those frequency
bands can be represented both by
a dtft, which is the thing
we just did on the last slide,
and by sampling theorem
expression, which is what we get
when we take the inverse
Fourier transform of the dtft.
So when we do that what we get
is a perfectly arbitrary
frequency function which exists
from minus infinity to
plus infinity.
We can represent it as the
sum of all these separate
frequency functions.
I just threw a limit in the
mean here because I'm not
being careful about what happens
where we separate from
one frequency function
to the next.
Namely, at frequency w do I use
one term or do I use the
other term or do
I use the sum.
But we don't want to
worry about that.
We don't want to even
think about it.
So we put a limit in
the mean here.
So the v sub hat m of f then is
going to be the part of u
of f which is in this particular
frequency range.
That's completely the analogy
of taking a time function,
looking at that time function
over a particular range of
time, and here what we're doing
is taking a frequency
function, segementing it into
different frequency intervals
so that the end frequency
interval is then just this
with a rectangular function
to truncate it.
If I take the inverse Fourier
transform of this what I'm
going to get is u of t, take the
inverse transform of all
of these terms, so I'll get
the sum of vm of t.
Now, vm of t is the inverse
Fourier transform of vm of f.
You take that quantity, take the
inverse transform of it,
and sure enough you get this
kind of expression here.
It's a sampling theorem in v sub
m of f with this rotating
frequency term here,
which is just the
thing that we had before.
So, all we're doing here is
starting out with some
arbitrary frequency function,
we're segementing it in
frequencies.
Each frequency band then has
a dtft associated with it.
When we take the inverse Fourier
transform of that
dtft, what we get is a sampling
expansion for that
particular frequency band.
So what this is doing here,
finally when we get all done
with this, is I'm just combining
the sampling theorem
expansion in each frequency
range, which
is what u of t is.
So I've taken u of t, I split it
up into different frequency
ranges, I've expressed what's
in each frequency range in
terms of a sampling theorem.
The sampling theorem terms are
these with these rotating
terms in them corresponding to
the mth frequency range.
This is completely analogous
then to the truncated sinc
function expansion
we had before.
This becomes a little more
sensible if we substitute a
sampling time, t,
for 1 over 2w.
Namely, all of these expressions
here are talking
about what happens when you
sample these individual
frequency bands at intervals
1 over 2w.
So we'll just call that capital
T to make the formula
look a little simpler.
Then we get u of t is this
limit in the mean of this
whole expression there.
So it's a double sum, it's
a sum over time, over the
samples, so there's one term for
each time, kT, and there's
one term for each frequency
interval.
Frequencies are indexed by
m, time is indexed by k.
So the thing we have here is an
expansion now in terms of
coefficients -- these are just
called coefficients again.
This expansion which looks
suspiciously like the t space
truncated sinusoids that
we had before.
The only difference is that,
the terms were truncated in
time; here, the terms are
truncated in frequency.
So the different terms making
up this expansion, these
orthogonal terms here, in one
case what we have is a sinc
function which is translated
in time and then
translated in frequency.
In another case we have the
rectangular function, which is
translated in time and then
translated in frequency.
So in that sense, these two
expansions are almost the
same, and you can think of doing
expansions perhaps in
other things also and we'll talk
more about that later.
So, this then is just this thing
we're going to call a t
spaced sinc weighted
sinusoid expansion.
So the only thing we have is
this one sinc function which
is this hat sort of function.
The terms in here are those
functions shifted in time by
some number of sampling
intervals, t, and then shifted
in frequency by some number
of frequency bands, 2w.
See, the original frequency
bands that we had went from
minus w to plus w.
The next one goes from
w to 3w, the next one
goes from 3w to 5w.
So the frequency bands we're
talking about here
are of width 2w.
The time intervals we're talking
about are of width t.
Why do people confuse
you that way?
Well, because all of this
happened a long time before
people realized how closely
the duality relationship
between time and
frequency was.
So people wanted to talk about
frequencies, baseband
frequencies.
You talk about a baseband
limited to w and you're
talking about positive
frequencies, because engineers
used to deal with cosines and
sine, and there weren't any
such thing as negative
frequencies.
Then they decided everything
was easier when they dealt
with complex sinusoids, negative
frequencies reared
their ugly head, but people
didn't want to change their
notation for what a frequency
band was,
which is probably good.
So we're simply stuck with
this incompatibility of
dealing with frequencies one
way and dealing with
time the other way.
We can look at that as
increments of time t, and
increments of frequency, 1 over
t, but, in fact, 1 over t
is 2w, so the increments in time
we're using in both of
these expansions, are t, the
increments in frequency we're
using are 2w.
Now, there's a relatively long
section in the notes talking
about degrees of freedom,
which is a
pretty important topic.
It's a little bit fishy
mathematically, but it really
makes good engineering sense.
It's an idea which is important
both in terms of
taking source wave forms and
representing them in
orthogonal expansions, and in
taking frequency functions and
representing them --
well, it is also important in
terms of taking things that we
transmit where you have bits
coming into an encoder.
We're going to turn those bits
into signals, we're going to
turn those signals
into wave forms.
Those wave forms will usually
be thought of as things that
we transmit in time, and we
also transmit them in
frequency, because we often use
some kind of multiplexing
between different
frequency bands.
We want to have a common way of
thinking about all of these
things, and this is the way
that we're going to do it.
Namely, if we're thinking in
terms of a particular sampling
time, t, and we want to look
at a very, very large
frequency band, and therefore,
look at many multiplex
frequency bands, we can say how
many coefficients can we
send on this channel?
When we look at it in these
terms of different frequency
bands, the number of
coefficients we can send is
over a period of time, t zero.
We can send t zero
over t different
coefficients in time.
We now look at frequency.
We have some very broad
frequency band, w zero.
The number of different
bands that we have
is w zero over 2w.
As a result of all of this when
you add everything up,
you get 2t zero w zero degrees
of freedom over this overall
bandwidth of w zero.
Now remember, an overall
bandwidth of w zero in terms
of these complex frequencies
goes from minus w to plus w.
Minus w zero to plus w zero.
The time interval goes from
minus t zero over 2 to plus t
zero over 2.
So this factor 2 here, which we
always talk about in terms
of number of degrees of
freedom, is really a
consequence of the fact that we
measure time intervals and
frequency intervals in a
slightly different way.
But anyway, whether we look at
it in terms of one expansion
or the other expansion the
answer we get is the same.
If you take some large time
interval, some large frequency
interval, tuck as many numbers
as you can in that interval,
this is what you come up with.
Now, why did I say that this
is just slightly fishy?
Well, it's slightly fishy
because if you take a function
and you truncate it in time --
if we take this function and
truncate it to minus t zero
over 2 and plus t zero over 2,
even though that might be ten
years, how can we limit
the frequency?
Well, we can't.
Because when we take the Fourier
transform of a time
limited function, it exists
for all frequencies.
The same thing happens if we try
to limit it in frequency,
it squirts out forever
in time.
So you can't get around that.
The thing that saves us is that
if t zero and w zero are
both large enough, these
functions all dribble away
quickly enough that it doesn't
make any difference.
You know it has to.
If you think in terms of the
sampling theorem, and you try
to think about it carefully in
mathematics, what does it say?
If you want to transmit a
function by putting these
little sine x over x hats
around each of the
coefficients in the function,
when do you have to start
transmitting those wave forms?
You have to start transmitting
them at minus infinity.
I mean we turn on our
transmitter and we somehow
have to have been transmitting
for an infinite amount of time
before we send the
first symbol.
Well that's ridiculous,
of course.
So that we always approximate
these sinusoids by sinusoids
which are truncated, and we
always have some engineering
faith that what we're throwing
away is not important.
The only place that it's
important is when you start
talking about things which are
really zero everywhere and
then it becomes important.
But the idea of degrees of
freedom is a very sensible
idea until you try to express
it precisely.
Let's get on to something
called aliasing.
We're going to spend most of
the rest of today talking
about aliasing.
I want to try to explain why
it is that we want to spend
time on this, because
there are really two
things going on here.
One of the things that are going
on is that if you want
to look at a wave form and do
some processing on it, the
usual way to do it with the
digital technology we have
today, is to take that wave form
and sample it very, very
rapidly in time.
Then process the hell out
of all those samples.
We do that hardly caring whether
it's band limited,
hardly caring about the
information in it, hardly
caring about anything, we just
want to sample it so fast that
we essentially approximate
the function very well.
Now when we do that something's
going to get lost,
because when we take those
samples we're ignoring what
happens between the samples.
In some approximate sense, wave
forms are always smooth
because they always get filtered
by something before
anybody looks at them.
And because they're smooth, if
you'd sample it fast enough,
your fast enough samples
are going to look
like the wave form.
If you just connect them with
straight lines you're going to
get a very good approximation
of what the wave form is.
But then you stop and ask, and
when you stop and ask you're
in trouble because you say well,
how fast do I have to
sample, and if I sample that
fast, how much error am I
going to make?
That's the question for which
aliasing gives you the answer.
So we want to explore
it for that reason.
The other reason that we want to
explore it is when we start
talking about modulation, we'll
start talking about
something called Nyquist
criterion, and that's best
looked at in terms of aliasing
again, and we'll see why that
is when we get there.
So for both of those reasons,
and also for the reason of
trying to understand these
expansions in terms of source
wave forms, we want to
understand what this
relationship is between the
samples of a function that
isn't quite band limited and
the function itself.
So the thing we're going to do
to try to understand that is
instead of studying just the
samples, which is what you
usually do, if you're just
looking at the samples and
you're trying to say how much
error do I incur by doing
that, and we're looking at mean
square error, somehow or
other we have to get back to
wave forms and compare the
resulting wave form with the
wave form we started with.
So the thing that we're going to
do is to take our function
u of t, we're going to sample
it at some very rapid speed,
and then we're going to take
those samples and recreate a
wave form by the sampling
theorem.
So we're going to call the
approximation to u of t some
approximation s of t -- s of t
is, in fact, baseband limited
at this point to a frequency w
where t is equal to 1 over 2w,
and we simply have this sampling
theorem applied to u
of kt, as if u of kt came from
a band limited wave form.
So this is, in a sense, an
interpolation formula.
It's a little better than
taking these samples and
joining them by straight lines,
because we're, in fact,
joining them by these smoother
sinc functions.
The question is how close is s
of t to u of t and how do we
look at that question?
Well, we now have a nice way of
looking at it because after
going through this t spaced
sinc weighted sinusoidal
expansion, we have an exact
expression for u of t, which
is the limit in the mean
of these frequency
terms in u of t.
Namely, to get this expression,
remember the thing
we did was to take arbitrary u
of t, split it up into little
frequency bands, each of width
w, then apply the sampling
theorem to each of those
frequency terms, which we can
do exactly.
So this, in fact, is an exact
expansion -- don't worry about
the limit in the mean right now,
we're going to get rid of
that in a while.
So we have s of t,
which is this.
We have u of t, which is this.
Now, we look at this and we say
OK, s of kt, namely, the
case sample of s of t,
is simply u of kt.
That's what happens here.
You put in any old time which
is some integer j times
capital T and you look at this
expression here, and the sinc
function is only non-zero when
j capital T over t, when if
you take the sinc function of
an integer it's zero unless
the integer is zero.
The sinc function goes through
zero at every integer point
except for zero itself where
it's equal to 1.
That's the thing which makes
the sync function nice.
It dribbles away --
2, 3 and so forth minus 1.
So it's zero at all those sample
times, so that the case
sample of s of ts of kt is
just equal to u of kt.
Namely, what we're doing in this
approximation, which is
what one usually does if one
samples something, is we're
assuming that the approximation
is correct at
the sample points, and we're
arranging it so it's correct
at the sample points.
So, s of kt then is equal
to u of kt from this.
u of kt from this --
OK, now take t and substitute
k times capital T in here.
And if we substitute k times
capital T in here -- let's
not, let's substitute j times
capital T to avoid a conflict
with notation here.
Then this T here becomes
jT and what we have is
sinc of j minus k.
So we have a sum here over all
k of sync of j minus k.
Sinc of j minus k is zero for
all integers k, except for j,
therefore, this quantity
is zero every time k is
not equal to j.
Therefore, we just have
the sum over m.
So, s of kt is equal to u of kt,
which is equal to the sum
over all frequency bands,
m, of v sub m of kt.
Now what is this saying?
The thing this is saying is if
you take this function u of t,
which has a bunch of different
frequency bands in it, each of
those frequency bands has
a sampling theorem
associated with it.
Each one of those frequency
bands is represented by its
samples at periods of time, k.
But as soon as we look at u
of kt, if we only have the
samples u of kt, there's no way
to tell which frequency
band it's coming from.
So all of these different
frequency bands
all get alias together.
If I just look at u of kt, what
it is is the sum over all
these frequency bands of the
samples of the individual
frequency functions.
So that if you tell me what u
of kt is, I can't tell you
what these samples are.
All I know is what the
sum of them is.
So, in fact, if you start out
with a function which instead
of being baseband limited to w,
in fact, is sitting between
w and 3w, and there's nothing
in this baseband, and I look
at these samples and then I
recreate things this way, what
am I doing?
I'm just taking that function
at w to 3w and translating
down in frequency
to minus w to w.
You can't tell.
There's no way to tell just
from the samples which
frequency band we're
looking at.
So all these things get
mixed together.
So, s of t then, since s of
t is this times these sinc
functions, and this is the sum
of all the vm's, s of t is
just this double sum now where
all of these are now down at
this baseband frequency
interval.
There's no way to
tell them apart.
We have this double sum here so
I'm adding up all of these
different coefficients and
they're all mixed together all
down in this one
frequency band.
So, u of t is represented this
way, double sum, vm of kt, vm
of kt, sinc of t over t minus
k, sinc of t over t minus k.
This rotating term up here,
an s of t, what I've done
effectively is to get rid of
all these rotating terms.
It simplifies it enormously,
but I changed the function.
In fact, this function is low
path limited to w and this
function has all of the glory
of an arbitrary set of
frequencies in it.
By just looking at these
samples, I've lost all of this
stuff and it's just back down to
a baseband limited function
at this point.
So, if I look at the difference
between u of t and
s of t, what I'm going to get
-- and this is expressed a
little differently than the
way it is in the notes but
it's the same thing -- just the
sum over k and m, and it
has these sinc functions
in it, which both
of these terms have.
Then u of t has these rotating
terms and s of t doesn't, so s
of t just has one in place
of the rotating term.
So the difference between u of
t and s of t is just this big
monster sum here, which is
looking at all the different
frequency bands at all the
different sampling times.
If I now try to look at the
energy difference between u of
t and s of t, because that's
what I'm interested in -- how
much error have I accumulated,
how much mean square error
have I gotten?
By taking u of t and sampling
it and then viewing it as a
low pass function.
This energy difference, well, we
have a set of coefficients
here, we have a set
of functions here.
These functions are all
orthogonal to each other.
Why are they orthogonal?
Well, because sinc functions are
orthogonal, which I think
we've shown on our homework, and
space time functions are
orthogonal.
So, all of these functions
are orthogonal to --
excuse me --
spaced frequency functions are
orthogonal to each other, and
the sinc weighted functions are
orthogonal to each other.
So all I'm doing here is
expanding all of this in terms
of these orthogonal functions.
I have to do this separately
for these terms --
I know what happens.
This works when it's cold and it
doesn't work when it's hot.
Interesting.
So I'm separating this into
this term and this term.
Now, look at what this is
when m is equal to zero.
When m is equal to zero, e to
the 2 pi i, zero t over t
minus 1 is zero.
So, all of the m terms here are
collapsed into zero, so
there isn't any error down
at baseband in a sense.
All of the error occurs due to
these frequency terms larger
than minus w to w.
Well, that's the way
it should be.
Because we know that if u of t
didn't have any terms outside
of minus w to plus w, the
sampling theorem would be
absolutely rock solid
with no error.
So the errors are due to
two kinds of terms.
One, they're due to these terms,
which is this thing.
Two, they're due to these
terms, which is this.
The only difference between this
is that this is a square
of a sum and this is
a sum of squares.
Sum of squares are nicer, we
can deal with them more
nicely, and we understand
what that is better.
A sum and then taking the square
of it after we take the
sum is a good deal dirtier.
The trouble is that
this difference
doesn't have to be L2.
In other words, the mean square
error we got from doing
this can be infinite.
One of the problems in the
current problem set is a nice
simple example of this.
So, s of t need not have
finite energy.
That's a real kicker, because
all of this theory is very
nice until this point.
I mean the sampling theorem
works perfectly because when
you're dealing with baseband
limited functions --
for up baseband limited
function, the sinc functions
give you a perfect
approximation.
Namely, the sampling theorem
works with no error at all.
As soon as you get a function
which spills out into higher
frequencies, you can, in fact,
have these samples coming up
with infinite energy in them,
and at that point this
difference here can have
infinite energy.
In fact, you would do much,
much better if you simply
represented u of t by zero.
You'd do infinitely better in
terms of mean square error
just by throwing it away and
saying I'm not going even
bother to approximate it.
I'll just call it zero
and nothing else.
If you did that, you would only
have the error in u of t
and you wouldn't have all this
generated stuff from all these
terms that you're
throwing away.
When we start looking at random
processes, and really
the only thing that we're
interested in here is random
processes because noise
is a random
process, signals are random.
So when we start looking at
random processes, the thing
that we're going to find is that
this square of a sum in
terms of expected value is going
to be approximately the
same as this sum of squares.
So that this term and this term
are going to be roughly
equal for most of the stochastic
processes that we
deal with, so this problem
doesn't occur of s of t having
infinite energy.
What that means is that
these two terms are of
roughly equal magnitude.
Now, we can understand
something more
about these two terms.
The term here is what you get,
namely, these are the parts of
u of t which are outside
of the frequency range
from minus w to w.
A reasonable alternative to
simply sampling this function
would be to filter the
function first.
If you filter the function first
what's going to happen?
These terms will go away.
These terms will stay.
You still have the aliasing --
you can't get rid of that.
But you can get rid
of these terms.
Excuse me.
I take that back.
I seem to have a binary problem
today, whatever.
I seem to be mixing up
proof and falsehood.
If you filter a function you're
clearly going to get
rid of all of the aliasing,
because after you filtered the
function you will have
a band limited
function sitting there.
So the only error you're going
to get is the error in what
you've thrown away.
What you've thrown away is, in
fact, this quantity here.
Slow down, say it right.
What you have thrown
away is all of the
extra frequency terms.
So the error is all of those
frequency terms that you've
thrown away.
These are the frequency terms
that you've thrown away.
This is the error that you wind
up with after you filter.
These terms here are
the aliasing terms.
These are the things which, in
fact, could be infinite if
you're unlucky enough.
These you can get rid
of by filtering.
So now the question is should
you filter first or should you
just sample and say
to hell with it?
Well, if you think about why
you want to sample and use
digital signal processing, what
you're trying to do is to
avoid building very complex
analog filters.
So if you try to build a very,
very sharp filter which is
getting rid of all of those out
of band terms, you're sort
of throwing away a lot of the
reason for trying to sample to
start with.
So the usual conclusion is no,
we're not going to filter
first, or we're only going to
have a very crude filtering
operation first, and we'll just
sample a little faster if
we have to, because sampling
faster is easier.
So we usually just sample faster
and avoid these terms.
Now we want to look at aliasing
viewed in frequency
terms, and we've almost
been doing this.
We've been sort of talking
around it a little bit.
We're viewing an arbitrary
function, u of t, in terms of
a sum of these frequency
limited functions.
We're just arbitrarily taking
a function, splitting it up
into these frequency bands.
In terms of frequency what
we're doing is just
segementing the Fourier
transform u of f.
As far as the samples are
concerned, uf of kt is just
equal to the sum of the samples
in each of these
frequency bands -- that's
what we've been saying.
That's really what aliasing
is at a fundamental level.
So when you sample you can't
tell which frequency band each
of these samples come from, and
they usually come a little
bit from each one.
So, s of t now, I'd like to
split up s of t in the same
way that I split up u of t.
I'd like to split up s of t,
even though I can't do this
from looking at s of t, I can
do it mathematically.
I want to split up s of t into
the contributions to s of t
from all of these
different bands.
So I want to view the mth
frequency band as the sum of
vm of kt times sinc of
t over t minus k.
Namely, look at what s of t was
to start with, somewhere
back here a long time ago.
What we found was that s of t
is equal to this quantity
here, which is the sum over
time terms, the sampling
terms, and a sum over
frequency term.
What I'm doing now is I'm just
defining s sub m of t to be
this sum in here for one
particular value of m.
I'm just splitting this
double sum into a
number of separate terms.
So this is the contribution
to s of t from the
mth frequency band.
So, s of t is the sum of all of
these different frequency
contributions in this quantity.
vm of t, which came
from u of t, same quantity here
except for the complex
exponential here. vm of t is
the same quantity with the
rotating term at
the end of it.
Namely, this is the actual
signal at this
mth frequency band.
So the contribution to it and
the sampling approximation is
this, the actual term is this.
So we look at these two and we
say gee, this looks like -- if
we look at this in the frequency
domain this looks
like just a frequency shift.
So the thing we can then say is
that v sub m of f, namely
the Fourier transform of this,
differs from the Fourier
transform of this just
by a frequency shift.
If we take the frequency shift
formula and frequency and look
at it in time it just becomes
that rotating term there.
Namely, frequency shifts look
like complex exponential
multipliers.
We already know that d sub m of
f is the mth frequency band
and u of t.
So in fact, it's u of
f truncated to the
mth frequency band.
That's what this said .
So, u hat of f rect ft
minus m is just equal
to this term here.
So this says that s hat of f,
which is the sum of all these
terms, is just the sum over m,
sum over all the frequency
terms of u hat of f plus m over
t times a rectangular
function of ft.
All this is saying is that s
of f in frequency, it's all
down at baseband now.
Each of these frequency terms in
u of t, up at some band and
frequency, when we sample it,
we're effectively bringing it
down to base then.
When we sample it and multiply
by the sinc functions we're
bringing it down to baseband.
So this is saying when you look
at this approximation,
the space band approximation,
what we wind up with is this
frequency function evaluated at
all of these different --
well, just evaluated
at different times.
So, s hat of f is, in fact,
frequency limited to minus w
to plus w, and it has all
of these different terms
contributing to it.
It's just looking at aliasing
and frequency instead of
looking at aliasing and time.
In both cases it's
the same thing.
In one case, all of the samples
get mixed together.
In the other case, all
of the frequency
bands get mixed together.
I hope this will be clearer
in terms of this.
Let's take some arbitrary
function here -- a most
amazing thing, these
things all get.
It seems as if latex -- a thing
for drawing pictures is
fine on my screen but not fine
when I print things.
But anyway, this is
fine as it is.
It's slightly different from the
one in the notes, which is
also goofed up in
the same way.
Let's suppose we start out
with a frequency function
which looks like this.
Actually, it should have
something else
there but that's OK.
This is minus 1 over 2t,
this is plus 1 over 2t.
In other words, minus w to w.
Here we have another frequency
band from w to 3w, another
frequency band from 3w to 5w.
What that formula said is that
each frequency band gets
picked up and stuck down
in the baseband area.
So, in fact, what's happening
is that this part of the
frequency function is
going to be picked
up, stuck down there.
So this goes over there.
This quantity here is in
the band from 3w to 5w.
It gets picked up and
put in here also.
It's gotten picked up
and put down there.
So I have this part, this part,
and this part just stays
where it is -- this
is the part that's
actually band limited.
So that s hat of f now is going
to be the sum of this
and this and this, and one
disappeared term which was
supposed to be here, and that's
going to come in there.
When you add up all of these
-- this goes over to there.
you get the total frequency
function s hat of f.
All of you understand the
mechanics of this?
I mean graphically you can
just find s hat of f from
taking all of these things and
folding them all into this
baseband approximation.
So that you can look at the
error that you get in terms of
sampling a function which is
not quite band limited in
these terms, also.
The aliasing then looks like the
translation from something
which is in this band stuck
into the main band between
minus w and w.
Translation of this thing stuck
into the main band.
Translation of this stuck
They're all added together in
such a way that you can't tell
which one came from where.
So once you look at this, you
can't go back to here, which
is why people call
it aliasing.
These things are all just mixed
together and there's no
way to get back.
The theorem that corresponds
to all of this, and the
theorem is pretty much proven
in the appendix if you
want to read it.
If you're not interested in
those mathematical details
you're certainly welcome
not to read it.
I'm not going to have
any problems on it.
I'm not going to have any quiz
problems on it, we might have
a problem on it.
It turns out that just L1 and
L2 is not enough when you're
dealing with aliasing.
Aliasing, since you're both
sampling and looking at things
at arbitrarily large
frequencies, the mathematics
just gets messy.
So the condition that you need
is that the frequency function
you're dealing with in order
for all of these aliasing
results to hold true, is that
the limit as f goes to
infinity of u hat of f times
some function, f to the 1 plus
epsilon has to go to zero.
In other words, this is saying
that u hat of f has to go to
zero with increasing frequency
fast enough.
It has to go to zero a little
faster than 1 over f.
If it went to zero, it was
1 over f, that would be
guaranteed by a thing, L2.
That's not enough here.
You need the stronger
condition.
So if it goes to zero fast
enough as f gets very, very
large -- you know any function
you're going to deal with you
can always model it so
that it does this.
Because you simply can't
transmit wave forms that have
arbitrarily high frequencies
in them.
I mean no matter what kind of
antenna you use to transmit
them, if it's an optical antenna
you can get to much
higher frequencies, but no
matter what kind of antenna
you use you're going to be
limited somehow in frequency,
and it's going to drop off much
faster with increasing
frequency than this.
So this isn't any sort of
practical limitation on
aliasing, it's just that it's
there and it limits the models
you can create somewhat.
If you have this condition then
it says that the Fourier
transform of u of t has
to be an L1 function.
The inverse transform,
u of t, has to be
continuous and bounded.
In other words, when we go from
u hat of f to u of t we
get a bonafide function there.
It's not something which
is a limit in the mean.
Because as soon as we're
dealing with samples of
something you really need a
function to talk about.
You can't have something
which is --
well, you can't have something
which has these little extra
things on it.
You can't live with that.
So the theorem says that
this frequency
function has to be L1.
It says the inverse transform
has to be
continuous and bounded.
We've already seen that L1
functions have continuous and
bounded Fourier transforms.
For any t greater than zero,
the sampling approximation,
namely, s of t, which is this,
is going to be bounded and
continuous.
And s hat of f satisfies
this relationship here.
So this is the frequency
version of
the aliasing formula.
Here you still have the limit
in the mean here.
As soon as you go back to
frequencies you can't say
anything precise anymore.
In time, everything
is precise.
These functions are bonafide
functions.
In terms of frequencies
they're not quite.
I want to just start talking
about these L2 functions.
As you realize, we've not only
been talking about L2
functions, we've been talking
about L1 functions also, and
now these crazy functions
which go off
to zero fast enough.
The thing we're basically
interested in, aside from
sampling, is the L2 functions
because they're the ones where
you can go from function
to Fourier
transform and back again.
They're the ones which work or
these orthogonal expansions,
and they're the main things
we're going to
be interested in.
When we try to go further
talking about these functions,
it turns out that it's much
easier to think about them in
terms of vector spaces.
Some of you probably have
thought about wave forms
before as vectors, some of
you probably haven't.
I'm sure all of you are familiar
with vectors at least
in terms of a notational
convenience as a way of
representing n tuples
of numbers.
You can always take an n tuple
of numbers and instead of
writing out u1, u2, u3, up to u
sub n, you can say vector u,
and you can manipulate those
vectors, you can add vectors,
you can multiply them by
scalers, you can do all of the
neat things that people do, even
without knowing anything
about vector spaces.
It's not much of an extension
on that to take accountably
infinite sequence of numbers and
represent it as a vector,
especially if you've never
done it before.
If you've done it before and
if you've thought about it
before, you will realize there
are some problems there.
But at least conceptually
there's no problem.
You can think about a sequence
of numbers as being a vector,
you can add those sequences,
you can multiply them by
scalers, you can do all sorts
of neat things with them.
Since we've shown how to
represent wave forms as
sequences of coefficients in
orthogonal expansions, it then
isn't much of an extension to
think about wave forms as
being vectors.
But the nice thing about doing
this is that you're not really
stuck to a particular
orthogonal
expansion when you do this.
You can think of wave forms as
being vectors in just as nice
a sense as you can think about
these n tuples as being
vectors, and that's what
we're trying to get at.
These orthogonal expansions
we're going to be looking at
are really viewed most easily
in terms of vector space.
All of the questions about
convergence of orthogonal
expansions and things like that,
limits and all of that,
all of these are very natural
in vector spaces.
They're so natural that people
often forget about the fact
that they're taking
limits even.
So it just looks nice there.
But as soon as we do this, what
we're going to be doing
constantly from now on is trying
to say what we know
when we're looking at
two-dimensional vectors, we
have all sorts of
pretty pictures
about how they behave.
We are going to be trying to use
those pretty pictures in
two-dimensional space to
understand what happens with
wave forms, and in order to do
that we have to know a little
bit more about vectors than just
vectors are things you
can add and multiply
scalers by.
So I will bore you for two
minutes by quickly going
through the axioms of
a vector space.
My reason for going through
this is when you define a
vector space axiomatically, then
you can, in fact, prove
that wave forms satisfy
all those axioms.
Once you prove that wave forms
satisfy all those axioms, then
everything you know about
two-dimensional and
three-dimensional vectors and
all of that stuff all applies.
Namely, everything which is
general for vector spaces
applies to these vectors.
So the axioms are
the following.
You start out with
a set of elements
which you call vectors.
In terms of n tuples, the set of
elements is just the set of
different n tuples.
You also start out -- well,
for here we don't have to
worry about scalers.
So we have the set of n tuples
now, or perhaps it might be a
set of sequences or a
set of wave forms.
The things we insist on before
we will call this set a vector
space are that we have
an operation
which we call addition.
Fortunately for n tuples,
addition is what you would
think it would be.
It's element-wise addition.
For sequences, it's element-wise
addition again.
For wave forms, it's
function addition.
You have communitivity --
you can add things
in either order.
I mean look, if nobody pointed
this out to you, you'd do it
anyway, right?
So that it looks like nothing.
But in fact, you can invent
things, mathematical objects,
which you can deal with which
are not communitive.
So this is saying to be a vector
space it has to have
this communitivity operation.
Associativity --
again, it's hard to see why you
would say something like
this, but all we're defining
is this addition operation,
namely, there's a definition
of addition, and we know by
axiom that the sum has to
be in this vector space.
As soon as we assume this
associativity axiom, it says
OK, this is a vector in the
space, this and this are both
vectors in the space.
Therefore, this sum has
to be in the space.
Therefore this plus the sum
has to be in the space.
What associativity says
is that that's the
same element as this.
Once you see this you leave out
the parentheses because
you can add as many things
as you want to.
Same thing -- well, here there
has to be a unique
vector, zero --
v plus zero is equal to v for
all v, and there's only one
vector that has that property.
We're going to see some problems
there in a little bit
when we start studying these
L2 functions, but we'll do
that next time.
Finally, for every v there's a
unique negative vector so that
the sum is equal to zero.
All the operations that
you're used to.
We'll go through the other
things next time.